hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
unveil the immune response to cancer and
infectious disease with powerful
immunoassays
i am jennifer woods of labroot and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
sigrun
padrena product development manager
thermo fisher scientific
segrent you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you very much for the
introduction
and again welcome everyone to this
webinar
which will provide insights into essay
solutions to explore
major questions around the host immune
response to cancer and infectious
disease
so unraveling the interactions between
the immune system
and cancer cells or pathogens such as
viruses
is key to understand and potentially
control both cancer and infectious
disease
as depicted in the figure on this slide
the immune system is an extensive
network
involving numerous cells and molecules
including a large number of cytokines
and chemokines that shape local
and systemic immune responses
there's evidence for a dual role of
inflammation
also in the context of a cancer
involving several cytokines
which are either cancer promoting or
rather support
anti-cancer responses and treatments in
conjunction with soluble receptors and
the ligands of t
cells and inner immune cells including
natural killer cells
as summarized in the figure on the right
that are critical players in
immuno-oncology which rapidly emerges as
a research field
focusing on innovative therapeutic
approaches
that take advantage of an individual's
immune system to fight a cancer
so a hypo inflammatory state of the
immune system also known as a cytokine
storm or cytokine release syndrome
has not only been described as a
possible side effect of cancer
immunotherapies
but also as a common complication of
various other pathological conditions
including infection
by the novel severe acute respiratory
syndrome coronavirus starch cov2
such an overactive inflammatory response
can cause collateral
tissue damage as the immune system tries
to expel the virus
by recruitment and infiltration of
immune cells
into infected tissue so high levels of
inflammatory soluble factors
including interference interleukins
colony stimulating factors or tumor
necrosis factors as outlined in the
table
can contribute to the symptoms of
sarcoma to infection
that might range from mild to more
severe respiratory
or even life-threatening conditions with
dysfunction of multiple organs
so in this state immunosuppression by
selective blockade of cytokines is
likely to be beneficial
thus there's much interest to uncover
the complex
interplay between soluble mediators
implicated in the cytokine storm
and to further elucidate the dynamic
changes and interactions
between the immune system tumor cells
and viruses such as sarcome
so one way to better understand
differences in the immune responses of
subjects is to look at biomarkers apart
from soluble factors and secreted
proteins such as cytokines and
chemokinesis mentioned
this can include immunoglobulins immune
cells involved
intracellular proteins that play a role
in
immune signaling pathways or specific
receptors and surface proteins
that are of particular relevance in
immuno-oncology
or key entry targets for sars cop2 such
as the angiotensin
angiotensin-converting enzyme qh2 that
serves as a host cell receptor
so finally analyzing all these
biomarkers and soluble factors of the
immune system
will help to identify differences in
cytokine repertoires
and to characterize changes in the
pattern of proteins and other target
analytes
in order to relate them to specific
mechanisms underlying
pathological conditions
for research purposes uh the extensive
portfolio of in-vitrogen branded
immunoassays
meets a wide range of needs so from
build it yourself
immunoassays by choosing from our large
selection of antibodies proteins and
other reagents
to elisa kits for single target protein
measurement
including coated yourself elisa kits
with matched antibody pairs
as an affordable option for less
stringent requirements
to validate that ready to use analyzer
kits
and newer platforms like pro quantum
which are
highly sensitive homogeneous assays with
low sample consumption
using proximity based qpcr amplification
for protein target
quantitation on any pcr instrument and
finally
multiplexing solutions on luminex-based
systems for measuring multiple proteins
or rnas simultaneously in one world
in this webinar i will particularly
focus on immunoassays in the elisa
format as well as on multiplexing
solutions
that have been specifically designed to
support both
immune oncology and source sarskovic
research
so with over 700 targets in vitro
analyzer kits
are a cornerstone to measure cytokines
involved in pro-inflammatory responses
also for such cov2 research in a recent
publication aside that here
eliza kits were used to measure several
cytokines including
al-17a tnf-alpha or il-6
to better understand immune
dysregulation of pneumonia induced by
sars crew v2
in this case a unique signature of
dissolvable mediators
could be indeed identified in subjects
infected with
sarcoid u in association with the
macrophage activation syndrome
and defective antigen presentation
driven by il-6
which could be in part or rescued by
addition of a specific il-6
receptor blocker
for highly multiplexed targeted gene and
protein expression studies
nvitogen essays make use of the
multi-analyte profiling technology
that is compatible with any luminex
instrument
to provide a flexible high throughput
solution in a quantitative format
so with the incorporated branch dna
technology
quantity chemplex assays allow for
accurate multiplex
gene expression profiling of up to 80
targets per well
directly from a blood tissue homogenate
or life sample without the need for rna
purification
while procartaplex immunoassays for
protein quantitation enable the
simultaneous detection of up to 65
targets
in a single sample of plasma serum
cell culture supernatant and other
bodily fluids
requiring only 25 to 50 microliters of
sample material
thus combining the efficiency of
multiplexing
with the accuracy sensitivity and
reproducibility of a traditional elisa
in fact one instrument platform enables
analysis of multiple rna or protein
targets in the sample of interest
and thereby providing a comprehensive
analysis solution
for a transcriptional and the proteomic
level
importantly these multiplex essays may
be customized
by either selected selecting any rna
transcript
or by choosing from a portfolio of more
than 300 protein targets
from human mouse and other species
covering cytokines
chemokines growth factors but also
coagulation factors
immunoglobulins biomarkers for
immuno-oncology or sars kobe 2 and many
other areas of biology and research
the multi-analyte profiling technology
is
uh basically based on proprietary
macplex and microplex microspheres so
called beads
with a magnetic core and pore poreless
terrain surface
that are internally color-coded
resulting in 100 unique spectrally
distinct sets
or bead regions that can be individually
identified by one of the luminix systems
so each beat set is assigned to a
different analyte
and conjugation of a target specific
antibody to a distinct feed set for
protein quantitation
or using target specific probes to
capture rnas
finally allows analysis of multiple
analytes
and in essence gives rise to up to 100
different assays in a single well
the two instrument lasers are one laser
to excite the beat dye
and one green laser to excite the fico
eritrean detection dye
enable a classification of this the
respective speed region
and quantitation of the target analyte
in parallel
so how can this uh technology and
platform assist source coveted
research on the brocadeplex platform a
curated
uh panel for cytokinestorm
research combining 21 selected and
highly relevant
targets for inflammatory cytokine
profiling is available
in addition to pre-configured panels for
immune
monitoring and besides customized
combinations of available targets using
our mix and match offering
to design a unique panel for source code
to research appropriate to your needs
to further characterize the host immune
response to sars kobi 2 and a
transcriptional level
the targets for cytokinestorm research
are also available on the quantity chain
platform
and there's highly customizable assays
quantity ginplex that can incorporate
host antivirus targets in the same panel
allowing the relative gene expression
data to be obtained for these targets
from the same sample
custom research panels on this platform
can
include up to 49 targets relevant for
starting such covetous infection
so by combining immune related
biomarkers
with targets relevant for the viral
infection process
this gene expression analysis can help
to compare the transcriptional response
and to better understand the molecular
basis that may underlie sars cubic
induced infection
in collaboration with professor angela
slit from the university of rhode island
the performance of a quantitative
singleplex assay for detection of sars
cov2 viral rna
was evaluated for research purposes so
for this purpose three different rna
samples extracted from
another pharyngeal swabs that were
provided by the rhode island department
of health
with known ct values from qpcr testing
including a sample with low high and
very high positive qpcr
signal together with the reference
material were tested
to showcase linearity the estimated copy
number was graphed against the relative
light unit signal
demonstrating an excellent performance
with an r square of 0.98
corresponding to qpcr results
so an aspect that is of particular
interest also in this research field is
the humorous immune response to sars qb2
as summarized in this figure actually
four main structural proteins
are have been identified that are
implicated in source code to infection
and replication
including the envelope the membrane the
nucleocapsid and the most prominent
spike or s-protein
which mediates the viral entry into host
cells by
interacting with a stew as a receptor
on the host cell recent evidence also
suggests
additional factors to potentially
facilitate the viral host cell entry
which points out that there are still
mechanisms that need to be further
explored in more detail in this dynamic
research
field so as the virus enters the host
cell
and following replication release and
subsequent and ingestion by antigen
presenting cells
fragmented viral antigens are presented
to t
cells which in turn interact with and
activate b
cells that finally secrete
sarcomere-specific antibodies
of different classes including igm iga
or igg a certain portion of these
antibodies is capable
to neutralize specific viral antigens
thereby blocking their interaction with
the respective host cell receptors
and potentially prevent sarcoid
infection
so understanding of the antibody
mediated adaptive immune response to
sars kovitu is key
not only to define testing strategies
but also in view of the development of
vaccines and other future treatment
options
and will require reliable serological
tests
in addition to other powerful
technologies and tools for sarcoid
research serological assays will allow
to evaluate
the zero prevalence to monitor dynamics
of antibody titans over time
and to finally determine the extent and
duration of potential immunity in
subjects
following such cov2 infection or
vaccination
to assist researchers conducting
epidemiological or other research
studies
our portfolio of sarge kobe 2 research
tools
is also complemented by serological
immunoassays
to finally provide a comprehensive
solution for
exploring host immune responses at each
stage
during the course of viral infection so
besides profiling of cytokines related
to the cytokine storm
and analysis of viral rna and other
target analytes on the transcriptional
level
our serological immunoassays will allow
accurate detection of
sarcomere to specific antibodies and
further characterization
of the neutralizing capacity
in this regard i would like to introduce
two new serological immunoassays for
research purposes
a multiplex brocardiplex panel as well
as one of our available assets for sars
kobi 2 research in the eliza format
the human sars kobi 2 spike ig total
elisa
combines the spike trimeric structure
immobilized to the surface
and total antibody detection with the
flexibility of either qualitative or
quantitative readouts providing one of
the best
platforms for sensitive and specific
detection of sars cubic you
antibodies taking a look uh at
the workflow of this assay which uses a
spitrameric protein as
specific viral antigen coated onto the
surface of a 96 well plate
the binds total antibodies to source
copio present in the blood plasma
or serum sample these bound complexes
are then
detected by a horseradish peroxidase
conjugated antibody
and following an incubation step with
the substrate finally
results in a colorimetric readout over
the short
time to result of only one hour and 15
minutes
evaluation of the performance of this
elisa
included 39 pcr confirmed stars could be
two positive samples from convalescent
subjects
and 160 pcr negative control samples
as shown by the two bar charts here on
this slide
two samples from a subject declared pcr
positive
were identified as negative with
detected
signals below the set cutoff as
illustrated in the upper bar
chart however the samples were confirmed
to be negative also in other serological
assets that were performed overall
underlining the excellent
specificity and sensitivity of this
elisa
a further screening with control samples
positive for
other respiratory viruses including
influenza a b
or power influenza strains did not show
any cross reactivity with the spike
extraomeric
protein as depicted in the graph a high
control
indicated in red a calibrator to define
the cut off in yellow and the low
control
indicated in green are also provided as
part of the sli effect kit
except for three pcr-positive samples
here indicated in orange that could be
reconfirmed all
tested control samples here in blue were
below
the set cutoff finally resulting in 100
percent a specificity of the essay
benchmark testing of the invitrogen
branded elisa to an
essay of another supplier currently on
the market
showed some discriminate results for
certain samples as indicated by the red
errors in the two graphs so one healthy
negative sample
that was identified as borderline in the
in vitrogen essay
indicated in green in the upper bar
chart however was found to be above
the set cutoff and thus identified as
false positive in the competitor
essay as presented in the bar chart
below
furthermore three pcr confirmed positive
samples that could be verified in the in
vitrogen analyzer
were found to be borderline or clearly
below the cut-off level
and thus identified as false negatives
in the competitor assay
overall the in-vitrogen elisa shows more
samples with results as expected
and therefore outperforms the other
suppliers essay regarding specificity
and sensitivity
so besides the sarsko v2 ig total elisa
the new serology multiplex panel on our
prokartoplex
platform provides a comprehensive
screening tool to capture antibodies to
more than one source could be too
specific antigen
and allow us to distinguish antibodies
to these subsets of tsarskovitew as well
as to other related coronavirus
strains while saving time and also
resources
a solid knowledge of the charge qvt
protein structure and homology to other
coronavirus
strains is crucial to understand how the
virus acts and also affects
the host immune system so while the n
or nucleocapsid protein primarily
primarily regulates viral rna synthesis
the spike or s protein plays a critical
role in mediating
fusion and viral entry into the host
cell as mentioned
so as illustrated by the
three-dimensional schematic drawing of
the structure
the eso spike protein assembles into a
trimer to finally form the distinctive
crown-like appearance and comprises
multiple parts
an n-terminal as one sub-unit including
the receptor binding domain that
specifically recognizes the host
as2 receptor protein and the c-terminal
s2 membrane fusion subunit
as summarized in the table n and s
proteins show varying degrees of
homology between
the other six strains of coronaviruses
while the m-protein shares about 90
percent amino acid identity
with the previous stars coronavirus
sarsko b1
and about 50 with the middle east
respiratory syndrome related coronavirus
the s protein shows less structural
similarity to other coronas various
strains which is particularly low for
both
the n and the s protein between sars
kobi2
and the four listed endemic coronavirus
strains which are also called common
cold coronaviruses
taking a closer look at the design of
this 11 plex panel
which enables the detection of total
antibodies against
four different source cov2 antigens
including the nuclear capsid protein
the spike protein and the subdomains
that are considered as the most
immunogenic as well as to the s1 subunit
of six
other coronavirus strains next to a
negative control
so this broad epitope coverage is a
unique and integral part of this
serological multiplex
essay which provides a more complete
antibody profile
and consequently increases the
sensitivity and the likelihood of
predicting immunity status
among various spike protein domains
the s1 subunit shows the lowest homology
between these coronavirus
strains which which makes it more
specific to starscop2
antibody detection and allows to
differentiate between coronavirus
strains including the four endemic
strains of common cold coronaviruses
that are quite prevalent in the general
population
however cause only mild respiratory
symptoms
so the recent evidence supports the
hypothesis that
pre-infection with this common cold
coronaviruses
may provide immunity also against sarsko
v2
in this regard a pre-existing t-cell
mediated immune reactivity to surge cove
that has been
observed to some extent in the studied
population
and is supposed to be caused by prior
infection with this common cold
coronaviruses is discussed
this is quite an interesting finding
which might have also implications in
view of
vaccine development and should therefore
be considered
and this common cold coronaviruses
should be further monitored
however these findings need to be
confirmed and
also more evidence provided
to uh to to have more thorough evidence
the human coronavirus ig total
prokartoplex panel was evaluated by dr
doug frazier at the western university
and lawson health research institute in
stratifying studies of
intensive care unit subjects with dars
kovichew antibodies
14 healthy controls 14 sars kobe 2
infected icu subjects and 14
non-starch copity-infected icu subjects
were included
and blood plasma samples profiled at
different time points
so as illustrated in the box plots the
mean fluorescence intensity signals four
immunoglobulins against four different
sarcophagu
antigens demonstrate robust immune
responses over time
with a significant increase in sars
cavity
immunoglobulins in sarge kobe 2 infected
icu subjects here indicated
in red as compared to healthy controls
and non-starch kobe 2 infected icu
subjects
already at day 2 and even more
pronounced from icu day 3 on
analysis of the complete plus massage
kobe 2 antigen responses using a
state-of-the-art machine learning
algorithm as depicted in the tsne plots
on the left
reveals a distinct discrimination
between healthy controls
here indicated in green and sars copy to
positive
icu subjects indicated in red
with increasing classification accuracy
over time
that reached one hundred percent on icu
day three
table d lists the relative importance of
each of the source code ii anti-chance
between the groups showing a predominant
however equal contribution of the spike
protein and its subdomains
as compared to the nuclear capsid
protein
similar results were observed when
comparing complete plasma source could
be to antigen responses between
starch copy to positive icu subjects and
non-starch cobitu infected icu subjects
on respective days so
similarly the plots on the right
demonstrate a clear differentiation
and stratification of these two groups
of critically ill subjects
further underlining the excellent
performance of this multiplex essay
regarding specificity and sensitivity
so apart from sarge kobe 2 research a
powerful immunoassay is designed for
targeted approaches as well as for broad
immune profiling of multiple biomarkers
are also available to further elucidate
the interaction between the immune
system
the tumor and tumor environment and to
explore
all facets of immune checkpoint pathways
and support cancer biomarker discovery
and verification
across key immune oncology research
areas
so among the key research areas in in
immuno-oncology
cancer vaccines have evolved as a
strategy to stimulate a strong
immune response and to support a robust
antigen presentation
based on antigens and neoantigens
released by cancer cells upon cell death
besides the cameric antigen receptor t
cell or abbreviated
car t cell therapy and immune checkpoint
inhibition
that are two of the most promising and
rapidly emerging approaches
so while car t t-cell therapy further
expands the adoptive cell therapy or
transfer
relying on the re-infusion of a
subject's t-cells after specific
genetic modification which finally
enables them to recognize and destroy
cancer cells
the approach of premium checkpoint
inhibition is based on therapeutic
antibodies
targeting immune checkpoint pathways as
a normal way to attack tumor cells
immune checkpoint pathways are critical
in balancing immune responses in order
to protect
tissues from damage when the immune
system is activated
however a cancer cells can disregulate
these immune checkpoints and through
ligand receptor interactions
use them as mechanism to ultimately
evade
immune surveillance
as pointed out by the figure on this
slide among the first immunotherapies to
market were targeted to blocking the
effects of
cytotoxic t lymphocyte antigen 4 ctla4
and program cell disc 1 pd1 with several
therapeutic antibodies currently
approved as immunotherapeutic
trucks ctla-4 plays a role during the
priming of t
cells by antigen presenting cells and
the combining to its ligand b7
acts as a negative regulator of t cell
activation and proliferation
blockade of the ctl4 receptor by
specific antibodies however can boost
t-cell activation and thereby drive an
anti-cancer immune response
the immune checkpoint protein pd1 is a
regulator of apoptosis and a critical
for
maintaining t cell expansion during the
immune response
binding of pd1 by its ligand pdl1
expressed by a cancer cell
can mask cancer cells from t cell
recognition and finally
attenuate immune responses since the
discovery of cancer therapy based on
inhibition of negative immune regulation
via ctla-4 and pd-1 that has also been
recognized with the nobel prize for
medicine or physiology in 2018
many strategies and agents have been
developed to target these immune
checkpoint markers
which are actually in clinical trials or
are used in combination therapies that
are
promising to enhance anti-tumor immunity
this has also encouraged the research
field to further investigate immune
checkpoint pathways to potentially
identify a new drug target
also beyond pd1 and ctlr4
so in recent years a main focus of the
development of prokartoplex essays was
on immune oncology biomarkers for
investigating immune checkpoint pathway
functionality
in affected t-cells and natural killer
cells
which are evolved in the regulation of
both adaptive
and innate immunity taking a look at the
cancer immunity cycle on the left
which we are probably familiar with
schematically showing in
a seven step process how the immune
system combats cancer cells
initiated by the release of cancer cell
antigens upon cancer cell death
followed by the uptake and subsequent
presentation of cancer antigens
t-cell activation in the lymph nodes the
trafficking of
activated t-cell to the tumor side with
infiltration
into the tumor and finally the
recognition and killing of the cancer
cells
with release of antigens that further
drives this progression of the cycle
each of these seven steps is tightly
regulated
and involves the coordination of a
multitude of checkpoint molecules and
other cell surface receptors as well as
soluble factors such as cytokines
and chemokines so for many of these
factors we already provide multiplex
panels
such as four pro and anti-inflammatory
cytokines
which regulate step two and we have a
complete portfolio of chemokines
and adhesion molecules which regulate
t-cell trafficking
and infiltration so our immuno-oncology
checkpoint biomarker panels particularly
focus
on the steps three and seven t-cell
activation
and the killing of cancer cells
including the most important a
co-stimulatory and co-inhibitory
molecules
which are often engaged by cancer cells
to alter activation pathways and
ultimately attenuates immune responses
and thus these are also relevant targets
for immune checkpoint inhibitors
similar regulatory processes and
checkpoints can also be found
during init immune cell activation
including natural
killer cells as depicted in the graph on
the right
so a lot of receptor ligand interactions
are to be explored here as well as
potential
therapeutic targets that might mediate
anti-cancer immune responses
in addition to the important role of the
adaptive immunity
this also further points out that the
immune checkpoint molecules
are primarily recognized and considered
as transmembrane proteins
acting as receptor ligand pair however
soluble isoforms and shed variants are
described for the majority of these
molecules
that can function either as immune
adjuvants or decoy receptors and thereby
regulate a checkpoint pathways
this might of course has an impact on
the clinical efficacy of individual
checkpoint modulated drugs and thus the
immuno oncology checkpoint biomarker
panels have been specifically designed
and optimized for the measurement of key
immune oncology analytes in human or
mouse
serum plasma and cell culture supinated
samples
so as illustrated by the bar chart a
screen of more than 70 human melanoma
samples
finally proved and confirmed that all
these soluble forms of checkpoint
molecules
included in the immuno oncology
checkpoint panel 1 and
2 which are two predefined panels each
including 14 targets
are indeed detectable in serum
further evaluation of the immuno
oncology
checkpoint panel one revealed that
expression patterns of these soluble
markers
are dependent on disease state and
cancer treatment
so as demonstrated by the two graphs a
reduction of pd-1 levels was detected in
melanoma samples
comparing early treatment to
pre-treatment
and although we have in this case no
further details and insights into
treatment and respective responses the
results further highlight that
monitoring of these soluble checkpoint
molecules
might provide valuable information in
relation to the clinical outcome of
therapy
for early evaluation of treatment
responses
and such a characteristic responder
profiles might therefore help to
to pre-select and also stratify subjects
who may benefit from a certain treatment
moreover uh concentrations of soluble
checkpoint markers could also be
determined in human breast cancer
samples
um before and after chemotherapy using
multiplex immune oncology checkpoint
panels as
already published in 2016.
uh there's evidence that
chemotherapy-induced
tumor cell death is associated with the
release of intracellular molecules
such as the cell death marker high
mobility box group protein 1
hmgb1 into the micro environment
so notably soluble cd27 soluble cd80 and
pdl2
correlated with the hmgb1 level and
where increased in human samples
with a better response to neo-adjuvant
chemotherapy and the better five-year
survival
so this suggests that the immune status
differs between donors with increased
hmgb1 levels in response to chemotherapy
as compared to donors without increase
and
further underlines the relevance of
immune checkpoint marker monitoring
to better adapt treatment strategies
apart from the human pre-configured
panels mouse procata plex immune
oncology checkpoint panel
1 and 2 enable the monitoring of soluble
receptors and ligands
to support studies on the response to
potential therapeutic treatment also in
mouse models and have been validated by
a collaborator
in normal versus tumor tissues from mice
as demonstrated here in the two bar
charts analysis of in total
11 analytes in tumor tissue extracts
from non-treated and treated mice
revealed a distinct protein profile with
differentially expressed proteins in the
treated
as compared to the control group
suggesting a role
for these proteins in tumor progression
in addition to the immune oncology
checkpoint biomarker panels it is of
great interest to analyze a broader set
of immunomodulatory markers
also in the context of immuno-oncology
to get a more complete picture of an
individual's immune status
so the immune the human immune
monitoring fructoplex panel which
which is actually the largest available
panel on this multiplex platform
enables efficient immune response
profiling
biomarker discovery and validation by
analyzing
65 cytokine chemokine and growth factor
targets
simultaneously in a single well and is
complemented by
an easy to use software solution
to also enhance our data analysis
so overall prokartoplex immune oncology
immunoassay kids
allow simultaneous quantitation of up to
38 soluble immune checkpoint molecules
for humans
that are included in the immune oncology
checkpoint panel one
covering all the relevant soluble t-cell
checkpoint molecules
while the immune oncology checkpoint
panel 2 contains
soluble natural killer cell checkpoints
and are complemented
by additional targets in the immune
oncology checkpoint panel
3 which are now all combined in one
immune oncology checkpoint panel that
will be soon available
to ultimately enable the systematic
analysis of
all these soluble biomarkers and to
provide a more
complete profile of cancer immunity
besides several immune oncology
biomarkers for mouse
are combined in the mouse immune
oncology checkpoint panel one and two as
mentioned
and we further continued to expand our
portfolio of procataplex kits
for cancer researcher providing a cell
proliferation and metastasis panel
in addition to available targets for
angiogenesis or apoptosis
and there is also more coming soon to
support this key research area
if there is still a target of interest
which you can find in our product
portfolio you can take advantage of our
services
including contract development of
immunoassays which we provide for all
available platforms
or our customer sample testing service
if you do not have access to an
appropriate instrument or the capacity
to run the essay by yourself
you can send us your samples and get
your data without effort
and many other custom solutions that
help shorten the time
from sample to answer and to support
your research
finally please feel free to visit also
the new research hub on our website that
provides a practical guidance and
protocols and
contains a substantial technical content
including latest research
tools particularly for exploring the
vast field of
immunology so without that i will end
this presentation and i'm happy to take
your questions
now
thank you segren for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are the antibody response kinetics
to sars cov2 proteins
so uh that's a good question usually igm
and or iga are among the first
antibodies
um detectable within a few days upon
source curvature infection
and thus indicative of a more more
recent infection
while igg is a longer-lasting antibody
potentially also for monitoring of
long-term immunity
however the dynamics of the immune
response and antibody response can vary
depending on viral load and several
other factors
and some individuals do not even produce
detectable levels of antibodies
due to several reasons so um in this
case further long-term studies are still
required to better understand
um sars kubi2-induced antibody responses
and kinetics
in our portfolio of immunoassist for
sarcoid
research we are included um
ig total elite and procartablex
multiplex kits for detection of total
antibodies
as well as elisa kits specific for
detection of igm or itg
so you can choose the the essay
appropriate to your
research need and depending on the
research
question that should be answered uh as
shown
in the presentation uh the procataplex
11 plex panel was also used to study uh
total antibody responses to the four
different
sarcope2 antichanting icu subjects over
time
and more details on this study can also
be looked up in
in the labyrinth's webinar presented by
dr doug frazier
which is still available on demand
thank you siegrin our next question is
in view of recent reports on sars kobe 2
mutations
does the procardoplex multiplex panel
detect sars kobe 2 variants uh that's a
good question
so as with most viruses mutations
are common and uh they occur naturally
and frequently which means that the
variants are uh expected uh also for
stars kov2
uh since the human coronavirus ig total
pocatellox panel
is a multi-target assay so capturing
antibodies to more than one stars cavity
specific antigen
so that the broad epitope coverage as
mentioned is an integral feature
and in this context and in this case a
clear strength
at this time an impact on the overall
sa performance is thus not expected
as convalescent samples so from subjects
uh
previously infected with the source code
ii variant will still contain portions
of antibodies
directed against the epitopes that are
not affected by a certain
mutation however it cannot be excluded
that mutations might probably result
in exposure of new epitopes or a masking
of
existing epitopes so that the question
that remains to be answered is
whether and how this might then change
the immunoglobulin patterns uh
identified using the pukatoplex
multiplex panel
to date uh we have no evidence for the
impact of variants
in this regard
thank you again seagram our next
question here is
do you provide any assays for detecting
sars kobe 2 neutralizing antibodies
so yes indeed a sars kobe 2 neutralizing
antibody elisa
uh will be available very soon
which serves as a surrogate virus
neutralization test
meaning that it will determine the
neutralizing potential of antibodies
uh in in less than two hours without the
use of
of live virus or cells and and can be
performed
outside of uh biosafety level 3
environment as compared to conventional
virus neutralization tests so in
in in addition to the information on uh
the starch cover two specific antibody
titers that
can be obtained by using our serological
elisa's or the multiplex brocardoplexa
panel this elisa will also allow to
functionally
characterize antibodies so in terms of
the
neutralizing potency and as pointed out
in the presentation
functional uh neutralizing antibodies
are considered effective in
viral blockade and are this thus
indicative of potential protective
immunity following
sarcobyte exposure or vaccination so
this this
essay might also add value to
to studies uh on the immunological
memory
and that monitor also efficacy of
vaccines
all right thank you again sigrin and our
last question for today is
can immuno-oncology checkpoint multiplex
assays be combined with certain cytokine
targets
so yes so apart from from the
pre-configured panels
mentioned it's possible to either blend
essays for single targets of interest to
create
a multiplex panel or use a mix and match
offering to
to design a multiplex panel with
the targets of your choice and the
desired species and sample type
selected from the list of available
analytes
assisted and using the panel
configurator and selection tool
on our websites
thank you again segrent for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye